the pitch clock what do you think we
like this it's going to speed up the
game of baseball I feel bad for the
pitchers yeah I do I I do like it I like
it but I want to expand on it the game
needs to be speeded up when when it in
in all honesty I mean I I hate this old
school stuff and and the new schools of
this
um here's what it is
old school's good new school's good just
remember your ass is always in school
right no matter what you think no matter
what you think and so I think that
speeding up to the game it got to be
boring guys fixing their gloves every
time you get get in the batter's box and
hit when I was in a batter's box I
didn't get out of the batter's box to
adjust anything man get in the Box in
the head right Bobby Gibson Fergie
Jenkins Catfish Hunter Kenny Holtzman
Jimmy Palmer Seaver all those guys that
pitch a game in an hour and 50 minutes
by the blue
without a doubt right they could do that
three hours give me a break that's
horrible Reggie
come on the prediction who is winning
give me one team that will win this year
the name all of it everything well
everything
we've lost our best player the Astros uh
for eight to ten weeks that's going to
hurt us because he's a great leader and
great player plays 155.
but we have enough pitching we have the
best pitching I believe in baseball if
not then we're in the top two or three
and when you pitch you don't need a lot
of offense you need defense and pitching
and with the pitching we'll get to the
end
which means you will win 92 or 93 and be
at the end and if we get in the end
we're going to outpitch you and we don't
necessarily need to depend on our
offense Although our offense is better
this year because we have a Bray you we
got from the White Sox he'll drive in
100 he'll hit 30 so it will be at the
end I think the Yankees will be there I
don't know if they have enough pitching
um and I think they have a lot of swing
and missers
but they're still the Yankees how will
the Mets do Reggie
is that gonna happen success for me is
going to depend on the two big guys in
the rotation
will they get 50 starts out of them
because I think they're beyond the DL
somewhere
they're both 40.
right right so if they get 50 starts
you're going to be in postseason and
when you get pitching in post-season you
can beat anybody
Atlanta Atlanta
is good
don't underestimate Atlanta and the
Phillies are good
the Dodgers are good go ahead
you can't say everyone's good you gotta
winner I gave you five
pick a winner I'm gonna pick the Astros
s